all right now we've got s p 500 uh
as just the first chart uh let's just do
the uh the actual price chart itself
though stocks only go up right or at
least that's what facts uh
that's what uh has you know we've been
taught over the last 24 months or so but
why is that um and a lot of people think
they're getting rich just you know
especially asset holders um you know
everything's going up and to the right
but in reality uh it's more of a farce
and or maybe a focade and actually it's
just the money is debasing so what
happens if we standardize s p 500 and we
put it in m2 money supply terms uh it
looks a lot different and so what we're
looking at since 2020 if you just if you
just standardize uh this chart in terms
of m2 money stock the s p 500 is
basically flat um and so a lot of people
that think they've gotten pretty rich
over the last 18 24 months
in reality it's just a function of
monetary expansion um and so
this kind of
leads you to believe that the dollar
over the short term while
i guess the fed or other you know kind
of public officials would call it stable
it's actually a melting ice cube as some
would like to say uh and and if you're
valuing anything uh whether it's assets
goods services you know home prices
anything uh in bic and in dollar terms
uh you're gonna you're gonna it's gonna
kind of skew you to believe that things
are getting more expensive when in
reality uh many things are getting less
expensive it's just the currency the
unit uh is devaluing um and so here we
have uh a solution which is bitcoin
got it and so when you divide it by this
m2 doesn't look so hot and my guess is
that if you actually went ahead and you
denominated this in bitcoin obviously it
would be down significantly uh which i
think is uh your oh yeah it is your next
one of course you're two steps ahead of
me go ahead
yeah it's like little breadcrumbs right
like you're just this is like a little
game go ahead
yeah so i mean volatility obviously is
there uh you see in march of 2020 that
that big green candle but over the long
term um bitcoin is
the best unit of account you can use um
nothing else is absolutely scarce like
we've kind of covered and so
just denominating something as simple as
s p or even individual stocks in bitcoin
terms will lead you to be one of the
best uh or most ahead of the game
capital allocators out there i think
this is kind of the strategy for savvy
investors over the next decade and it
has been in the last decade but
increasingly i think it'll become the
standard as denominating your returns
against bitcoin
all right and then lastly you've got
micro strategy both against dollars and
bitcoin how are we looking
yeah so um talking about going on a
bitcoin standard valuing your your
company valuing you know your assets and
bitcoin terms here's microstrategy since
uh they've adopted a bitcoin standard up
282 percent um obviously some pretty
spectacular growth uh for for a company
that was was kind of treading water for
the last decade and now if we denominate
in bitcoin terms um they're doing
fantastic and they have 110 000 bitcoin
um but their unit their their share
price in satoshi's their share price you
know in bitcoin terms
has basically surprisingly or maybe not
surprisingly been flat right so so they
have actually kept pace with the bitcoin
standard um and so few companies can say
the same um and i think this will become
kind of the way that you know savvy
investors and increasingly everybody
will have to value things uh in the 21st
century uh bitcoin is the most superior
unit of account uh and if you're valuing
things with bitcoin yes there's there's
short-term volatility but over the long
term uh you're definitely ahead of the
game and you'll you'll get a step on on
people who are not